since demolishing the Georgia Dome and
opening their state-of-the-art
mercedes-benz stadium right next door
the NFL's Atlanta Falcons have rewritten
the rules when it comes to concession
sales two seasons ago the stadium
unveiled a grand experiment in
professional sports
food and beverages that average fans can
afford Dana Jacobson reported on the
novel concept when it was first
introduced $5 beers and $2 hotdogs for
fans at mercedes-benz stadium have been
too hard to resist exactly what Falcons
owner Arthur Blank had in mind when he
told us about the fan friendly pricing
concept in 2017 I'd hear fans just
people around me just complaining about
it all the time so I you know said time
management team we need to price it
every day the same way they would pay
anyplace else they went in the city of
Atlanta you're a businessman
this sounds like this could also help
your bottom line in some way you know I
mean I think over time I think we'll see
that we're still trying to sort through
that our volumes are up dramatically but
they were in the Georgia Dome blank who
was on Wall Street last week to ring the
opening bell has received a big return
on his investment of family-friendly
pricing rich McKay is the Falcons
president and CEO our per caps meaning
what people average spent in our
building year-over-year first year in
the stadium versus dome 16 percent up
with a 50 percent decrease in price and
that was amazing it we did not foresee
that maybe Arthur did in its wisdom we
did the increased concession sales was a
win win for the Falcons higher profits
and happier fans in 2017 the inaugural
season for mercedes-benz Atlanta ranked
number one in the NFL in every food and
beverage category 2018 we repeated those
results number one in every category
it's not hard to figure out that if you
listen to the fans you do what they ask
they'll deliver so was this about making
money or was it the right thing to do
right thing to do right and the right
thing to do it's incredible how often
time leads to making money which is why
NFL teams like the Baltimore Ravens and
the Detroit Lions have followed the
Falcons lead something else Arthur black
had envisioned we're hoping that we'll
set an example for other people not only
in Atlanta really but throughout the
United States
he is absolutely been successful in that
gutsy smart move
Scot Rosner director of Columbia
University's sports management program
thinks Blanc has changed the next
generation of sports stadiums we talked
about lifetime value of customers and
the lifetime value of the customer for
the land a sports fan is I think quite
higher now because people want to go
there they don't feel like they're being
taken advantage of it's an affordable
experience in Baltimore the Ravens now
offer flock friendly pricing they
estimate a meal for a family of four
could be purchased for just $44 a
savings of 34% in Detroit this past
season fans could get a hotdog soda and
chips for $10 or with a beer for 12 fan
friendly pricing is also catching on
outside the NFL blanks Major League
Soccer teen Atlanta United which plays
at mercedes-benz is under the same
stadium pricing as the Falcons Major
League Baseball's Baltimore Orioles and
some college teams like the University
of Texas have also dropped prices did
you know right away that that was
something that might work for you know
we had to really study the numbers Steve
Koonin is CEO of the Hawks and State
Farm arena the fan satisfaction scores
for concession or the highest they've
ever been show people a good time and
they'll spend more in the end I think
it's show them a good value the quality
of what we're serving is it's important
it's a price that creates a value one
other key accessibility which was
something the team considered with the
arena's recent renovation from an
increase in the number of concession
stands to like the Falcons moving the
soda machines out from behind the
counter the speed of service is so
important because it's all about the
total experience
now we would have never done it at the
Falcons not done it but once you kind of
convert and believe there's a
deep-seated belief this is the right
thing to do and whether it's at State
Farm arena or back across the street at
mercedes-benz doing the right thing
means without exception so the pricing
in effect for Super Bowl fifty three
will be the same as it's been for every
event in the building I think the NFL
will come around to that I'm not sure
they loved it before well they may
appreciate it on Super Bowl Sunday when
they're paying their meals there will be
a there certainly be a volume they'll
see a volume like they've not seen
before
because people that will be in the
building for the first time are always a
little bit like really so I can have
these two hotdogs two sodas I can have
popcorn I can have a beer and I'm still
under $20 that usually shock some people
which may be why sports stadiums and
arenas may just be the beginning with
one of the bigger movie theater chains
reaching out to McKay and his team for
insight who've showed him everything we
got and we keep checking to say okay
when are you gonna pull the trigger I
had a chance to actually ask
Commissioner Roger Goodell about this
pricing model whether he'd like to see
it in other NFL stadiums and while he
said it was a bold move for Arthur Blank
to do this with the Falcons he also said
that it is up to each individual team
guys to decide what their pricing model
will be makes so much sense Dana it's so
simple but it makes so much sense so
many of us have been to games and you
feel like you're a captive customer and
being ripped off you know and nobody
would I feel ripped off yeah and also
one of the things that they said is they
were trying to figure out whether or not
when people spend less money on that
food and beverage do they spend more on
merchandise the falcons said it was hard
to judge because in their time the
falcons had been doing so well so they
couldn't tell if that's why people were
buying more merchandise but Steve Koonin
told me that he has noticed that people
are spending more money on those things
so it's like again it's that win-win
model for these teams that are trying it
don't just feed hungry people
[Laughter]